so leadership and authority are not the
same thing
title affords you authority affords you
rank right um but that doesn't make you
a leader i know many people who sit at
high levels of organizations who are not
leaders
we do as they tell us because they have
authority over us
but we don't trust them and wouldn't
follow them anywhere
and we i know many people at low levels
of organizations that have no formal
rank no formal authority but they've
made the choice to look after the person
to the left of them
and and and take care of the person to
the right of them uh and we would trust
them and follow them anywhere um and so
rank affords you the opportunity to lead
at scale
it affords you the opportunity to take
care of more people
implement systems and and incentive
structures and all the rest of it and
reward behaviors to to to to to you can
influence culture
with rank but that doesn't make you a
leader
and you still have to study the the
the the tenets of leadership
and and and when they align it's magical
you know when you have rank and and
you've been studying leadership then you
can then you can actually affect the
culture in a in a more robust way and
and one of the primary responsibilities
of any leader is to make more leaders
and and you can do that at scale if you
have authority
i always assume that leaders die
you know leaders move on they require
they retire they quit whatever you know
they leave and so we cannot
uh it would be a very weak movement if
it was driven only by the force of
personality of one or a few people who
will inevitably
move on
um and so the more that people feel like
the movement belongs to them
the more initiative they take to keep it
alive
while when the leader when the leader
leaves
so yeah a movement has to belong to the
people you know civil rights didn't
belong to martin luther king he he did a
very good job of articulating the vision
better than most
but it wasn't his it was ours it was
those who believed in the same vision
who who it belonged to and the more
vision is shared the more just causes
shared the more likely it is to survive
and thrive well well well beyond any
individual
every everyone has the choice to be the
leader they wish they had
you know leadership is a capacity
like being a parent is a capacity like
everyone can do it not everyone should
do it not everyone wants to do it but
everybody can do it and so
is the choice if somebody likes coming
to work and just you know getting their
job done and going home at the end of
the day we i have no gripe with that you
know um and i i still have the same
expectations that they become a a
trustworthy productive member of the
team that they look at for the people
around them but anyone who chooses to be
a leader
which has nothing to do with rank
which simply means that i will invest
time and energy to learn the skills to
look after the people around me
um even the people above me to express
empathy and concern and care but to go
back to your your your question about
self-doubt
um
like a parent to a child
one of our jobs is to help them build
confidence and one of the ways we help
them build confidence is to let them try
let them fail and let them try again
and let them learn the lesson that i can
do this rather than swooping in and
always doing it for them and because of
the pressures of
you know financial pressures and
whatever pressures are put upon us by
our organizations sometimes people in
leadership positions say i don't have
time for that yes sometimes it does take
time
and this is where i think
an infinite mindset is very very very
helpful